.
LET'S GOFRGOOD EEV
I'M KATE BOLDUAN IR ER
RIN TLY.EAST 4 KTHE EAST COA
HIS IS FIRST TIME
D A FLHIS
T HC 24 S IN NEWERERE'S NOOVER
ONIGHTTHNORTHEAST,
MOREPE IN , T
HARDEST HIT STATE WITH3 PELE
DEAD.
OFFICIALS SAY MANY MORE ARE
STMIAT THIS HO WE'REO OW TE ENT.
A BASEBALL FIELD, FLOODED.
THE OUTFER STANDS,
MP. GIVANHOW
FO ONLY WAY ATWE'VE ING RESCUED
DG.THERE ARE ALSOORD-BREAKING
FLOODING IN NEW YORK DIED,N FALO
HARD AND, EW
THATASNEY'IOUS RT ONHAES IN ONE
WE THAN THEITETS COUL.THISHW A
KER HIGHER GROUND.
TC.T'S HOW YOR
MONEY.
I'M HERE.
>> TR REALG YOE THAT
NEW YORK'S BACUP BEKNOCKED
OFFLINE.
WATER WAS SEEN JUST GUSHIN
THE IGHT
A
FLOODING SO FAST THAT SOME NEWYN
TIME.AY KEOUT IN
N
PEPESY N  ARE ALSNIOS.
, TRULY, NO ONE WAS KILLED AFTEO
LOOK AT
I MADE CLEAR TE GOVEAF
N, FEMA, IS  AE ALL
THE ASSISTANCET'S NEEDED.
HAVE REPORTERSGROURO WAT WITH J
"LI IN NONCHTHOW TH?
>> Reporter: BEHIND ME, YOOPLEA.
THEY WERE IN TAS R N.THEY I BE O
HIG S OF ALL OF THOSE OR
>> WE'RE STIINPLTHEIR
OE
HUMAN LOSSICH ARD TO
IN THHEASION OFME  G YONDED TON
OF WHICH IRPD
2  BOUND BROOK, ,  ROS8 orter: E
WACON TRACKS AND
PARTS OFSTADIUM.A R HIGH T NOWA
YORK, THESE PEOPLE LOS
EVERYTHING. >> HOW HIGH WAS TH
>> I WOULD SAYT LEAS
WHERE THAT LINE IS?HERE THE W W
>> OH, MY
>> Reporter: IT ALSTARTED
THNAVICE
ISSUINH FLOOK CITY FOR T  S 3 T
DAY, WHICH WASOT
PAIC PROBLATUNT.
THAT TURNED INTO THEE
ES OF INFALL IN OS WARNING.
>> INTENSITY Y BY SURPRIS INFRAD
IN SUBWAY IONS.
>> OH,
SOMETHING. R 11:30
SG THS NOOR THITY R
G TO HAVTH.
AND, E
FOLKS IN THIODY'VE S
FLOOBEFORE, BUT IN
WHAT THEY SAW LAST NIGHT.HAT WE
BEFORE.
ON, U , BUT, AGAIN, NOTHING KAT
I WANT T
E A TORNADO
, DESTROYING AT
ARWIWE
PAULA NEWTON IS  GROUND.
SHE'S JOININ N.
PAULA, HOW BAD IS THE DAMAGE
ter: KBERING
I, WANT TO SHOW YOU
THE DADE B
EA EIGHT TORNADOES
HING DOWN IN THE NORTHEA.
S PEOPRE LUC
DESTRUCTION.
THEY COULD SEE THE FUNL CLH OWSE
NOTICE OTHEIR
IR
BASEMENDA
MINUTES, IT WA YOUARER 3-LD GEM
>> I MTE
THREMINUTES.IT'S SOUTH , FARM TO
E  Y THINK IT
HAVEN HAYO WARNING?
T WOULD HAVE BEEN
DIRE FOR A LOT OF PE
U SEE ORE THERE THE  COMPLETELD
T.
ING FELT DIFFENTD EVT ING FORTU
THE VE SAYS
PEOPLE'S DREAM HOMES, TE,
AND THE NEXTION ISU
D?
I MEAN YOUEA
S IS NEW JERHOMA, AND THEY DON'
WHAT T WILL NKLY, RE THEWA TERF.
NEOU SORIFUL
>>> COHANK YRE.OW'V
TAY
SEEIHE DESTRUCTION, TH
LIVED THROUGH THISTEG YOU?
THE LA2 HOURS OR
YOU , LAST WAST
LOTS OF
E LITERALL
WHATMED LIKE
THEIS D TODA WE WE AROUND,RE RE
ANPL UNLOADEER
NTRTR GARAGES, TIRD S E LINING L
QUEENSHEM ARE EMIO
BECAUSE THESE ARD THEY HAVD
T OF TTHEIR CARS.
ON  MEANS ESE
MAKING A LG IN YOUE SCE
D ONESEOPLE HAVETHEY HOW, THESAS
THEM, Y KNOW, I'M
MEETING FOTHT TIMEEY HAVHES
BECAUS FOAL LI
GH
ON THE THAT BUTHET KNOW HOWY FE
LO.
S THE CASEE LIVES WERE LOSI WASO
THREE COULD NOT MA